lo que quiero hacer en este vídeo es ver
cómo nos quedarían las cuentas si en
este negocio del restaurante en vez de
andar rentando un edificio por 200 mil
comprábamos un edificio de 2 millones de
pesos lo que quiero ver es cómo quedan
las cuentas en términos de la utilidad
contable y en términos de la utilidad
económica entonces déjame pasar aquí
abajo y poner que compramos un edificio
de 2 millones le voy a poner aquí
comprar
comprar un edificio de 2 millones estoy
aquí es al inicio del año 1 pero
imagínate que pasa el tiempo pasa todo
el año uno aquí está el año uno y
conforme va pasando el año pues el
edificio se gastan los mosaicos se van
rompiendo las tuberías ya no funcionan
también y entonces aunque al inicio del
año uno valía dos millones al final del
año uno ya se desgastó y ahora ya sólo
vale 1.9 millones 100 millones de pesos
entonces su valor de mercado disminuyó
en 100 mil pesos y por tanto se depreció
entonces déjame ponerle aquí que tuvimos
una depreciación de pre si acción de 100
mil pesos 100 mil
pesos ok bueno ahora en términos en
términos de utilidad económica pues
estos 100 mil pesos no se los pague a
nadie explícitamente ya no se los estoy
nadando a nadie con un cheque ni nada
por el estilo no es efectivo que sale y
por tanto no es un costo de oportunidad
explícito sin embargo si es un costo de
oportunidad de la oportunidad de que
pues mira hay dos cosas que tenemos que
contemplar número uno de la oportunidad
de haber vendido el edificio al
principio y evitar perder esos 100 mil
pesos y ese es una primera cosa que
tenemos que contemplar o sea si hubiera
vendido el edificio no hubiera perdido
estos 100 mil pesos de acá pero hay otra
otra otro costo de oportunidad que
también tengo que contemplar que es que
estos 100 mil pesos pues me hicieron
perder otras cosas en el transcurso por
ejemplo ahorita como me compré un
edificio de 2 millones en realidad lo
que pude haber hecho es invertir estos 2
millones no sé en algún fondo de
inversión o en algún plazo fijo y a lo
mejor podía conseguir una tasa de 5% por
ellos entonces hay otro costo de
oportunidad que se conoce como costo de
oportunidad de capital
no voy a poner aquí costo de oportunidad
de oportunidad
esta es oportunidad de capital
capital y entonces si estos dos millones
los podía los podía invertir a una tasa
de 5% anual estoy perdiendo dos millones
de pesos por una tasa del 5% anual 5%
anual esto es 5 procesos 10 5 por ciento
de los millones esto es otros 100 mil
pesos
cien mil pesos entonces aquí tenemos dos
costos de oportunidad de otra forma de
pensarlo es que si al inicio del año en
vez de haberme comprado mi edificio
tuviera estos dos millones y los hubiera
invertido entonces hubiera evitado esta
depreciación si hubiera evitado que mi
edificio se desgastará y además
metiéndolos en el banco me hubieran dado
100 mil pesos bajen entonces esos son
los dos costos de oportunidad que
tenemos que contemplar ahora la
depreciación también es un costo para la
utilidad contable es un gasto si de
hecho los contadores y contemplan la
depreciación en sus cuentas y pues
contempla porque o sea justo los
contadores contemplan cómo se van de gas
desgastando el activo de la empresa y
tienen un sistema muy específico para
despreciar las cosas o varios sistemas
entonces por ejemplo los economistas son
muy prácticos ya realmente se fijan nada
más en el valor del mercado al inicio el
valor del mercado al final hacen la
resta y eso es cuando se desperece de
precio pero los contadores tienen otras
metodologías no sé a lo mejor podría
depreciar y equitativamente algo
digamos 20 años digamos si este edificio
de 2 millones se deprecia en 20 años
equitativamente entonces cada año se
precia 100 mil o bien hay otras formas
de hacer la contabilidad que por ejemplo
siendo un año ganaste mucho entonces
desprecias mucho uno de tus activos para
compensar un poco las ganancias y que no
tengas que pagar tantos impuestos en fin
hay varias formas de hacer la
contabilidad pero bueno para fines así
de que las cosas nos queden más o menos
simples supondremos que tanto para los
contadores como para los economistas la
depreciación de este edificio fue de 100
mil pesos
entonces vamos a ver cómo se ven las
versiones una vez más dejan de usar los
mismos colores voy a usar este rosa de
acá de nuevo estamos en el año 1 de este
lado hacer la versión contable los
ingresos los ingresos son de 500 mil
pesos eso no ha cambiado 500 mil y ahora
tenemos gastos por acá gastos y de estos
gastos tenemos varios verdad otra vez
tenemos la comida tenemos el labor la
renta tenemos el equipo de la comida que
damos que eran 200 no eran 100 mil mil
de labor también eran 100 mil de la
renta ahora como ya tenemos nuestro
edificio ya no tenemos que pagar nada y
del equipo todavía tenemos que pagar los
50 mil sin embargo ahora los contadores
tienen un costo adicional que es el
costo de depreciación voy a poner
depreciación que son estos 100 mil pesos
aquí le voy a poner 100 mil
entonces cuánto nos quedaría nuestro
ingreso antes de impuestos eso lo ponía
con color morado entonces el ingreso
antes de impuestos ingreso ahí eso no es
lo que quiero escribir ingreso antes de
impuestos pues que no sea la forma más
sencilla de pensarlo es que antes
teníamos que pagar 200 mil de renta pero
ahora sólo pagamos 100 mil de
depreciación nos ahorramos 100 mil pesos
y de esta forma estos 50 mil se
convierten ahora en 150 mil 150 mil
pesos muy bien estar acá es la versión
contable ahora ganamos 150 mil pesos
vámonos ahora a la versión a la versión
económica va a la versión este de los
economistas entonces una vez más tenemos
ingresos por 50 por 500 mil pesos 500
mil
pesos y ahora tenemos costos de
oportunidad costos va a poner así de
oportunidad tenemos los explícitos que
es la comida labor renta equipo aquí son
100 mil patata aquí también son 100 mil
de renta ya no pagamos nada de equipo
pagamos 50 mil
y hasta ahí se queda pero también
tenemos los implícitos ojo la
depreciación no es explícita porque no
estamos sacando el dinero pero si va a
entrar en los costos implícitos de nuevo
tenemos estos salarios perdidos en el
vídeo pasado eras un taxista entonces
realmente no es como que alguien te esté
pagando pero podemos pensar estos
salarios como lo que ganase siendo
taxista vale pero bueno déjame ponerlo
otra vez así como salarios perdidos
entonces tenemos salarios perdidos pero
ahora tenemos dos costos de oportunidad
que platicamos uno es la depreciación y
otro es el costo de oportunidad de
capital y entonces aquí le voy a poner
la depreciación depreciación salarios
perdidos depreciación y el costo de
oportunidad del capital va entonces
salarios perdidos habíamos dicho que
eran 150 mil pesos es lo que podías
ganar ciento siendo taxista depreciación
son 100 mil pesos
y costo de oportunidad de capital
también son 100 mil pesos entonces
observa quiero que veas que hay algo
interesante aquí en realidad si nos
ahorramos 200 mil de renta en términos
económicos pero en términos de
oportunidad en términos de oportunidad
no nos estamos ahorrando nada porque
justo esos 200.000 se compensan con la
depreciación y con el costo de
oportunidad de capital entonces salimos
igualitos quedamos otra vez en menos
100.000 menos 100 mil pesos
una vez más esto de acá es la utilidad
contable utilidad contable
contable y estoy acá es la utilidad
económica utilidad económica económica
muy bien entonces pues qué sucede o sea
a final de cuentas esto lo que nos dice
es que no hay una ventaja desde el punto
de vista económico verdad aunque
compremos un edificio en vez de rentar
lo entonces la lección es que pues no
importa como como modifiquemos nuestro
negocio siempre tenemos que considerar
varias cosas dentro de los costos de
oportunidad y ver si realmente eso que
hicimos en el negocio pues realmente
conviene de una manera económica bueno
nos vemos hasta la próxima